school leaders across the country are
still working out details on how and if
children will return to classrooms this
fall or will they learn remotely Wonder
Years actress and best selling author
Danica McKellar has written 10 books
that aim to make math and stem learning
fun and engaging for kids of all ages
and now McKeller is out with a new book
The Times Machines aims to help teach
second to fifth graders multiple
multiplication and division a kid I
can't do it I can't say it
Danika gonna have to help me with all of
it thank you for getting up early with
us so right now we would be in what's
called the Summer Slide people forget
things from the school year now on top
of the summer slide we've got the covin
slide how do those slides those gaps in
our learning affect math in particular
oh my goodness it's been such a tough
year for kids especially math see math
is different from other subjects because
it's cumulative so if there's one thing
that you miss or you forget it affects a
lot of other areas as well it's its
extra-tough
but look I my whole goal is to make math
as fun and silly and goofy and non scary
as possible for both kids and parents
because let's face it in an
unprecedented way parents are
responsible for their kids education I
mean it's it was just thrown on them so
many parents were saying I don't know
how am I supposed to do this I've got
emails to answer I've got job I've got
to make dinner it's like well you know
what I'm so happy that this is my tenth
book the times machine is coming out now
because now my Micheli math books span
all ages zero 16 I think I can help I'm
here to help yes no I'm just so thrilled
and what I'm really excited about for
the times machine is that learning a
multiplication facts is something that
is boring and everybody has to do but
often gets overlooked especially when
there are holes in the education and
there's not as much time so I came up
with a new way of teaching
multiplication yes to make it fun for
example six times seven
if you imagine like it's eatables 42
right if you imagine a six-sided block
of cheese and mr. mouse eats that what
every day for seven days six times seven
is six died of bug a cheese times seven
he gets full and farty - that is true
we have a glad we have streets out there
of the book because there's a there's a
little picture of you there in a comic
book image so there's like a paneled
comical okay how did you decide on that
oh why not teach math and the most fun
silly way possible with comics and
cartoons it just time-travel it coach
the times machine we have the time
travel I may be seen we go to the
dinosaurs you know we yes we travel all
over and and one thing I just want to
say about Karen's trying to teach their
kids math is that looks different now it
looks different from how it did when we
grew up there's all these other methods
they're all these new math vocabulary
terms so in the back of this book and
also dinner up in this math book which
is for first and second graders I have a
new math translation guide for grown-ups
in the back very helpful indeed you got
to show their work but your work was
different 30 years ago you know you
mentioned the the learning to exactly
this book is is kind of a replacement
for school and you know something about
trying to teach kids from home because
you've been homeschooling your son Draco
from the beginning anything you can
share about how to get learning done in
the home for all these parents trying it
for the first time yeah well I will say
I feel so grateful and lucky that been
homeschooling him this well time in it
hasn't been a big transition also very
grateful that I'm asked a lot of tips
and tricks and strategies for getting
your kids to focus at home getting them
to to have fun with it having the
parents have fun with it too I have and
I'll give you a couple tips now also
I've got all them on my Instagram page
if you go to my profile page but a
little circles little highlights click
on learn at home or school at home and
you'll find a bunch one of them is have
your child teach something to one of its
one of her or his stuffed animals this
works really well if Draco's not
focusing or he's getting intimidated by
something I'll bring out flappy a little
seal if he loves my people just look to
enter and all people I don't understand
what's going what
and he let light stopping like becomes a
teacher it's amazing rule is don't have
any toys in the area yeah so no toys in
the area unless if your child is
explaining a concept to a toy and
another one is act it out yeah like wow
I was gonna say acting out will be a
little bit easy for you and when you're
an actress but I know I know but you
know anything to get up and have it not
feel as school um as possible
totally worse so anyway I'm so happy
that I get to share tips with you guys
and also through my math books making
it's alright in fun and goofy and come
to me for any of your questions on
social media find you on social media
it's a book that's helpful for kids also
for parents because times have changed
they're doing math differently these
days believe it or not Danica McKellar
thank you very much I appreciate you
being on the x machine is on sale right
now